[Music]
the democrat party's losing its mind as
radicals in washington and on twitter
continue to drag its agenda further left
every single day the vast majority of
americans do not support open borders
socialism and insane gender and race
politics
but those are the only things the left
wants to discuss
it's gotten to the point where even bill
maher a former darling of the far left
is pulling the fire alarm and demanding
that democrats have a come to jesus
moment
i think they're going to get
thumped in the election i mean that
usually happens in midterm elections but
you know i mean joe look i'm glad he's
there
but uh he has not exactly stuck the
landing on a lot of the issues that he
was dealing with i keep saying this to
the democratic party
the reason why you're so toxic is
because you have become the party of no
common sense we are
should be moving toward a colorblind
society where we don't see race localism
we have to see it everywhere
joining me now the host of next
revolution steve hilton so that was a
quite an intervention there that uh bill
maher was staging wasn't it
it's amazing you love to see it it's
funny you say even bill maher but
actually if you watch what he's been
saying um if he's saying the democrats
of the party have no common sense he's
turned into the liberal who's constantly
making sense you know he's been saying
on the pandemic the pandemic is
basically over can't we just go back to
normal red states are better than blue
states constantly railing against cancel
culture and wokism and making clear how
racist it all is and it just tells you
how far left exactly as you're saying
that the democrats have gone they they
they've gone racing off and left bill
maher there as the sensible one but
what's interesting to me is the fact
that he's speaking out against it i i
suspect most of them know how lunatic
the whole agenda is but they haven't got
the courage to say so and they're all
kind of enthralled to the squad and
basically you've got only bill maher and
the other day you had james carville no
one else is calling it out yeah because
bill's you can't cancel him he's on hbo
he's got plenty of dough and he's you
know he's not old but you know he's had
a long career let's listen to what he
said about one of your favorite people
hunter run it
something like hunter biden i mean if
don jr had done what hunter biden had
done
it would be
every night all night on msnbc
but the fact that it's hunter biden
and joe's on the blue team see that's
the problem with america everything is
so binary
do you think cuomo
was processing that at all or not
it's just amazing isn't it it's you it's
so great i think basically maybe he's
had enough of hbo jesse and he's looking
for a slot on this channel because it's
just incredible to watch him in action
just calling out how crazy they've all
become the hypocrisy of the media i mean
it's just incredible he does that often
on his show and it's so true and cuomo
just sitting there he kept trying to put
himself in the position of well some
people might say this and take the other
side and try and you know desperately
trying to cling on to the democrat
talking points but he was having none of
it bill maher was terrific yeah i mean
in a way i hope that they don't listen
to bill maher i hope they keep just
driving this crazy train over a cliff
because you know that would benefit the
country politically but
i shouldn't say that you really do want
like a healthy rational
democrat party so you could maybe get
together and get something done for the
working men and women of the women of
this country um 30 seconds go ahead
well the trouble is it's it's so
divisive that's the thing it's all this
hate you know they are guilty of the
exact same thing they constantly accuse
everyone of elsev it's the division and
the hate they're constantly putting
people each other's throats and this
endless racism that's what's so
destructive that's what it is we don't
want it to continue it's a profit model
and we're on to them now i'll see you
later exactly hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else